>> Ed: SENATOR RICK SCOTT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
>> Sandra: FOX NEWS ALERT.
PASSENGERS ON BOARD THE GRAND
PRINCESS NOW DOCKED AT A PORT
IN OAKLAND AFTER BEING
QUARANTINED ON THE VESSEL OFF
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
THERESA DUNCAN JOHNSON IS ONE
OF THOSE PASSENGERS.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND JOHN WERE
ON ANNIVERSARY TRIP BEFORE THEY
WERE STRANDED AT SEA FOR DAYS.
SHE IS DISEMBARKING AT THIS
MOMENT AND JOINS US NOW BY
PHONE.
THERESA, GOOD MORNING.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Sandra: I’M DOING FINE.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN.
WE’RE GLAD YOU’VE BEEN ABLE TO
RETURN NOW.
WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU AND YOUR
HUSBAND NOW?
>> WELL, THIS MORNING WHEN WE
WOKE UP WE RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM  PRINCESS UNDER OUR DOOR
WITH OUR TAGS TELLING US WE
NEEDED TO PREPARE TO DISEMBARK.
THE LETTER BASICALLY SAID WE
NEEDED TO HAVE OUR LUGGAGE OUT
NO LATER THAN 7:00 A.M. PACIFIC
TIME.
SO WE HAD EVERYTHING PACKED
ALREADY.
GOT UP AND GOT READY.
NOW WE’RE JUST WAITING TO HEAR
THE CAPTAIN COME ON AND TELL US
THAT THEY ARE BEGINNING THE
PROCESS.
WE ALSO HAD HEARD YESTERDAY
THAT THEY HAD CALLED SOME
PASSENGERS BUT ENDED UP HAVING
TO COME BACK TO THE CABIN.
WE ARE HOPING FOR A BETTER
SITUATION TODAY.
WE DON’T KNOW IF WE’LL BE
WALKING OUT THE DOOR IN A FEW
MINUTES OR IF WE’LL BE SITTING
HERE FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL HOURS.
IT IS JUST KIND OF A STAND BY
AT THIS POINT.
>> Sandra: WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
TOLD ABOUT WHERE EXACTLY YOU’LL
GO NEXT?
>> WE LIVE IN GEORGIA, SO WE
ARE EXPECTING TO BOARD A
MILITARY TRANSPORT TO DOBINS
AIR FORCE BASE IN GEORGIA NORTH
OF ATLANTA.
>> Sandra: WHAT WAS THE
QUARANTINE PROCESS FOR YOU AND
YOUR HUSBAND WHEN YOU HAD TO BE
CONFINED TO YOUR CABIN ON YOUR
ANNIVERSARY TRIP KNOWING THIS
VIRUS WAS ON BOARD AND THAT
THERE WERE AFFECTED PASSENGERS?
>> WELL, I THINK THE GOOD NEWS
FOR US IS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
GET OFF THE SHIP, GO AND SEE
HAWAII AND WE DIDN’T FIND OUT
ABOUT THIS UNTIL WEDNESDAY
BEFORE WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
ARRIVE BACK ON SATURDAY.
WE KNEW WE WOULDN’T BE BACK ON
SATURDAY ANYWAY.
THURSDAY IS WHEN THEY
QUARANTINED US TO OUR CABIN.
WE DID WHAT WE WOULD DO AT HOME.
WE WATCHED THE NEWS.
WE’RE FOX NEWS FANS AND WE
WATCHED THE NEWS AND WE READ
AND WATCHED MOVIES.
ACTUALLY ADDED 300 MOVIES TO
OUR TV CHANNEL.
WE HAD THINGS TO ENTERTAIN US.
PRINCESS GAVE US A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES TO DO, PUZZLES AND
LITTLE CRAFTS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO GIVE US
THINGS TO KEEP US BUSY.
SO FOR THE MOST PART, YOU KNOW,
WE WERE JUST BASICALLY IN OUR
ROOM.
WHEN WE DIDN’T GET OFF THE SHIP
ON SATURDAY AND DIDN’T KNOW
WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO BE BROUGHT
BACK INTO TOWN TO GET OFF,
ANXIETY LEVELS DID GO UP A
LITTLE BIT AND YOU WONDER IF
YOU’LL BE ANOTHER 14 DAYS
SITTING OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE OCEAN SOMEWHERE.
THEY WERE REALLY HAPPY WHEN WE
FOUND OUT WE WOULD GET TO PORT
YESTERDAY.
>> Sandra: ANOTHER COUPLE ON
BOARD DID NOT HANDLE IT IT
SOUNDS AS WELL AS YOU AND THEY
DID NOT APPROVE OF THE HANDLING
OF THE PRINCESS CRUISE LINE’S
DEALING WITH THIS ACCUSING THEM
OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND SUING
THEM FOR A MILLION DOLLARS
SAYING THEY KNOWINGLY -- THE
SHIP WAS INFECTED FROM TWO
PREVIOUS PASSENGERS WHO CAME
DOWN WITH THE SYMPTOMS OF
COVID-19 AND HAD 62 PASSENGERS
ON BOARD.
DO YOU PLAN ON TAKING ANY LEGAL
ACTION AGAINST THE CRUISE LINE?
>> I DO NOT.
I THINK THAT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THEY HAVE COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
I GUESS EVERYBODY HAS TO MAKE
THEIR OWN CHOICE WITH THAT.
FOR ME AND MY HUSBAND, WE FEEL
LIKE PRINCESS HAS GONE ABOVE
AND BEYOND WHAT THEY COULD DO
IN THIS SITUATION.
WE HAD TO FILL OUT A
QUESTIONNAIRE WHEN WE WERE
GETTING ON BOARD WHETHER WE HAD
BEEN IN THE AREAS IN CHINA
BASICALLY AT THE TIME THAT HAD
BEEN INFECTED.
WE DID GET ON THE SHIP ON THE
21st OF FEBRUARY.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, THE PEOPLE
WHO CAME DOWN SICK WERE NOT
IDENTIFIED UNTIL SOMETIME AFTER
WE WERE ALREADY ON BOARD.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S PRINCESS’S
FAULT.
THEY MADE ACTION AND STARTED
DOING THINGS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THE PASSENGER DURING THE TIME
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED AND THEY
HAVE DONE A LOT OF THINGS FOR
US.
THEY GAVE US 100% OF THIS
CRUISE AND ALL OUR TRAVEL
EXPENSES AND EVERY WE’VE
PURCHASED ON TIME THEY’VE
COMPED ALL THAT BACK TO US PLUS
THEY ARE GIVING US A FUTURE
CRUISE AT 100% PAID.
I FEEL VERY FORTUNATE THEY HAVE
DONE SO MUCH MORE THAN I WOULD
HAVE EXPECTED BECAUSE WE DID
GET TO MAKE THIS TRIP.
WE DID MAKE IT TO HAWAII.
>> Sandra: IT IS ADMIRABLE AND
WE’RE THANKFUL THAT YOU AND
YOUR HUSBAND ARE DOING OKAY.
HAPPY ANNIVERSARY.
GLAD YOU WERE ABLE TO GET IN A
PORTION OF YOUR VACATION AND
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN,
THERESA.
>> IT WAS A PLEASURE SPEAKING
WITH YOU.
>> Sandra: WE WOULD LOVE TO